[Music]
[Applause]
sir your name is Greg Kirkland Greg
Kirkland and you were the choir director
choir director so your job really is to
assess people's vocal strengths and see
how they blend with the overall choir
absolutely make sure everybody is able
to sing in a group why don't you take me
through a simple test and then you can
assess me as a gospel singer okay I
don't sing gospel
okay never sang gospel it's just one of
those things I know I can do better than
anybody else
Swee that's all the words I know oh can
you give me some more of the words it's
it's something about the sound that
saved a wretch like me
I thought was a wrench no this wasn't me
saying a wrench like me you know I don't
see how you would ever be a wrench it
seemed rich laughs now the quiver I put
him there yeah that's something that I
picked up okay when I was very ill as a
child no it's actually a wheat allergy
if you want vibrato I like the sound of
that
things like a shop that's not necessary
Wow why would you add that what made you
spirit negative no no how about we start
you with something a little simpler
simpler okay how about we come on let's
try this is insulting to sing a verse
for me and I'll listen to you okay
ah sweet okay I'm gonna say we're about
the same this is me this is you you move
the hands and show me where you are
I'm noticing the robes here everyone
loves the the choir robes we don'twe
robes in rehearsal
you don't wear robes in rehearsal nobody
wins choir robes and rose okay
newspaper just came in and headline
Conan always wears robes okay
these are my robes do you think did you
wear this with the group because
everybody else behind us and yeah but I
pop in this robe super stick this is
Conan welcome home thank you see
actually it's Conan but the O fell off
because somebody used an inferior glue
it was a goose but I'll just be back
here and I'm gonna blend in you're not
even gonna know I'm here
[Applause]
I did I come in late yes a little cute
me a little off but we'll work that out
well you know what I think it's both of
our fault that's the mature me I'm back
down again
well would you like me to solo there no
well let's have a show of hands who
wants to hear my amazing grace
and who would really rather not hear it
the visitor here pretty good though can
we just give it a shot
[Music]
[Applause]
it just occurred it I'm sorry I'm sorry
I just
do you always direct pregnant yeah I
know he's the choir director that's just
but you know there's a pitch every game
like they take a rest now I'm gonna use
a few different motions and movements of
that's okay if you see this it means
soft like a butterfly this of course
means up this means down this means
let's drift sideways look if I do this
it means let's back this whole thing up
and if I do that it means you're getting
too close to the curb okay
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of movement and I'm viewing the
energy but I'm not seeing it I got a
couple of moves and you tell me which
ones you like the most
I got this one right here when I spin
and then I do that and then I pump water
right here I'm taking artisanal pizza
out of an oven the songs you guys are
doing they're fantastic did you guys get
this these are the possible side effects
if you take cymbalta did you get those I
just some why not get a little
information
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen here they are great
Kirkland jr.
in the Atlanta Fiat fire
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]